Animal shelters across the United States
have started teaching their
cats to give high fives
to make them more adoptable.
This is a true thing, it's happening.
They're teaching them, it's kinda cute.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, true story, true story.
They found that people are
much more likely to adopt
a cat that knows how to high five.
That's true, yeah.
As a result people have already been
adopting the cats in record numbers.
Here's some footage of the new act owners.
It's pretty cool, take a look.
Yes, thank you so much.
I'll see you Monday.
I got the job.
(hands slapping)
(audience laughing)
You finished all your broccoli?
Yup.
Good job!
(hands slapping)
Oh Hank, I'm almost done.
That's what she said.
(laughing)
(hands slapping)
Go get it.
(dog barking)
Good boy, you did it.
(hands slapping)
(cat meowing)
(heavy breathing)
(hands slapping)
(cat meowing)
(audience applauding)
If you can grab a still video...
I feel like if you can just grab a still
of the cat high fiving the dog, that is...
(laughing)
That's the worst damn
puppeteering you will ever see.
That's just a bottle brush.
I know.
(audience laughing)
We just have to be
honest with our audience.
That wasn't good.